il arrive d'abord par centaines et
deviennent des milliers tellement
nombreux que certains se tiennent par la
main pour ne pas se perdre pendant les
journées scolaires
les vedettes sont les auteurs jeunesse
comme roselyne brassait et son
personnage
juliette c'est enfin l'occasion de
savoir ce qu'on va présente nous livre
dans leur vie qu'est ce qu'ils aiment
dans notre écriture
comment il s'appelle pu échanger avec
lui ce qui les intéresse la jeunesse
saint quentin on voit ça aussi on
appelle ça le péril jeune
pendant la journée c'est le péril jeune
l'éditeur pascal assathiany a participé
aux 40 salon du livre de montréal et au
début il y en avait un petit peu
quelques classes mais c'est devenu un
partenariat dans le salon avec les
commissions scolaires et ça fait partie
des activités des jeunes
il y à 40 ans il y avait bien un peu de
livres pour enfants des petits comptes
n'est occupée là au coin du cendrier au
début le salon c'était plus une affaire
d'adultes et c'était plutôt au modeste
austère quelques centaines d'auteurs s'y
présentait dont bien sûr déjà michel
tremblay le salon de l'époque était
dominé par les grandes maisons d'édition
françaises
ce qui a vraiment changé c'est
l'apparition d'une multitude de petites
maisons d'édition québécoises qui publie
pas plus d'une dizaine de livres par
année
si à 40 ans il y avait peut-être quatre
cinq éditeurs québécois au salon
aujourd'hui on a 50 80
quantité un forain portion marché tient
à ses dires il ya quarante ans le livre
québécois ou canadiens français
représenté environ 5% du marché du livre
au québec
aujourd'hui c'est 45 % qu'est ce qui n'a
pas changé en quarante ans lotissement
qu'est ce qu'un auteur pense de la
situation du livre actuellement au
québec l'a été en tout cas
catastrophique jusqu'ici nous droit
d'auteur était jamais pays sauf
exception on devient toujours pas riche
dans le monde du livre mais auteur pour
la plupart ne vivent pas de leur film
des libraires ont du mal à les plus pas
son salaire minimum
les éditeurs travaillent
chez eux dans leurs caves ou des choses
comme ça donc l'ensemble n'y a pas
beaucoup de gens qui roule en rolls
royce pour rouler en rose russe ça prend
des bonnettes qui attire les foules et
qui font vendre de la copie des
biographies de gens célèbres par exemple
ça permet de rentabiliser sa présence au
salon parce que les sondes sont très
coûteux il faut en plus le personnel et
tout ça donc si vous n'avez pas de
vedettes qui vend des dizaines et
éventuellement des centaines
d'exemplaires nous est déficitaire à la
déficitaire à court terme mais plus
rentable à long terme avec tous ces
jeunes qui aujourd'hui prennent goût à
la lecture et au livre